>> THE EU FOREIGN
POLICY CHIEF SPEAKING VERY
BLUNT TERMS ABOUT WHAT THE
RESPONSE WOULD BE FROM NATO IN
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD THERE
BE A NUCLEAR WEAPON USED BY THE
RUSSIANS IN UKRAINE.
HERE HE IS, LISTEN TO THIS.
>> ANY NUCLEAR TALK AGAINST
UKRAINE WILL CREATE AN ANSWER.
NOT A NUCLEAR ANSWER, BUT SUCH
A POWERFUL ANSWER FROM THE
MILITARY SIDE THAT RUSSIAN ARMY
WOULD BE ANNIHILATED.
AND PUTIN SHOULD NOT BE
BLUFFING.
>> HOW WOULD THOSE WORDS BE
HEARD BY THE KREMLIN?
>> THE KREMLIN HAS HEARD THIS
BEFORE AND MAYBE NOT AS
DIRECTLY BUT I THINK THAT HE IS
REALLY BEING QUITE OVER IN THIS.
BUT THAT IS CERTAINLY PART OF
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO BE THE
POSSIBLE REACTION FROM THE
UNITED STATES, NATO ET CETERA.
TO ANY USE OF THE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WEAPONS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT UKRAINE.
THE WEST, ESPECIALLY NATO, DOES
NOT WANT TO REACT AND MAKE THE
SITUATION EVEN WORSE BUT
BEGINNING IN NUCLEAR WAR BUT
THEY COULD REALLY CARRY OUT
EXTREMELY DESTRUCTION OF THE
RUSSIAN FORCES IN THE FIELD.
PUTIN I'M SURE, BECAUSE WE'VE
HEARD THERE HAVE BEEN SIGNALS
AND NOT ONLY SIGNALS BUT DIRECT
WARNINGS TO WAR RUSSIA AND
PUTIN THAT THIS IS WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IF YOU DO THAT.
SO I AM SURE THAT IT IS NO
SURPRISE TO HIM.
IS IT GOING TO STOP HIM?
THAT IS THE QUESTION.
BUT, IT IS A VERY SERIOUS
THREAT.
>> WE ARE NOT THE DELICATE
POINT HERE.
THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS BACK
IN THE DAY.
SIMILAR PLACE RIGHT NOW.
JILL, AS ALWAYS THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH, US APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU JOHN.
CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH LIVE
IN CENTRAL UKRAINE FOR US.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THESE
LATEST STRIKES?
THIS HAS BEEN FOUR OR FIVE
NIGHTS IN A ROW OF STRIKES
AGAINST IN MANY CASES CIVILIAN
LOCATIONS.
>> Reporter: YEAH, LOOK, I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY WE ARE SEEING A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PATTERN, A
NEW PATTERN THIS WEEK SINCE THE
VAST WAVE OF STRIKES ON MONDAY.
THERE ARE PERSISTENT BIDS, IT
SEEMS TO HIT ENERGY OR OTHER
PARTS OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
LOCAL OFFICIALS SAYING VERY
LITTLE.
I THINK THERE IS A CONCERN TO
NOT PROVIDE A READOUT OF HOW
DAMAGING STRIKES HAVE BEEN
SIMPLY SAYING THAT ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN HIT IN
ONE OF THE DISTRICTS OF
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
NO TALK OF INJURIES OR PRECISELY
WHAT KIND OF DAMAGE OCCURRED.
THIS DOES APPEAR TO BE SOMETHING
RUSSIA IS TRYING TO CONTINUALLY
SUSTAIN.
HOW MANY OF THESE GUIDED
MISSILES DO THEY HAVE.
I SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT TARGETS
IS NOTHING NEW.
THE ONE THING THAT IS REMARKABLE
TODAY IS THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS
BEEN IN KAZAKHSTAN FOR A MEETING
OF REGIONAL COUNTRIES.
HE'S MADE AN INTERESTING COMMENT
NOT ABOUT THE UKRAINIAN WAR BUT
SAYING THEY NEED GOODWILL.
HE SAYS EVERYONE HAS GOODWILL
AND WE NEED TO USE THIS GOODWILL
TO THE MAXIMUM IN RESOLVING
CONFLICTS.
WE MUST STRIVE TO FIND WAYS OUT
OF THE CURRENT SITUATION
WHEREVER IT ARISES.
IN THE PAST BECAUSE THE KREMLIN
SAYS ONE THING AND DO THE OTHER,
WE'VE NOW HEARD FOR A NUMBER OF
DAYS THIS PERSISTENT NOISE FROM
MOSCOW ABOUT DIPLOMACY, ABOUT
PERHAPS FINDING A WAY OUT OF
THIS.
GIVEN THE PRESSURE PUTIN IS
UNDER DOMESTICALLY TO MAKE A
PUBLIC STATEMENT SAYING GOODWILL
IS REQUIRED TO FIND A WAY OUT OF
THE SITUATION, THAT IS A CHANGE
IN TONE CERTAINLY IN THE PAST
DAYS WHILE THEY UNLEASHED THOSE
WAVES OF MISSILES, THE NUCLEAR
RHETORIC WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST,
THAT HAS LESSENED THE RESPONSE
FROM THE WEST TO WHAT
POTENTIALLY MIGHT OCCUR IF
RUSSIA USED NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THAT HAS BEEN VERY FORCEFUL AND
VERY PUBLIC.
YOU JUST HEARD THE E.U. FORMER
POLICY CHIEF THERE.
A CHANGE CERTAINLY.
YOU MAY HEAR MORE FROM PUTIN IN
KAZAKHSTAN.
HE'S MEETING WITH HIS TURKISH
COUNTERPART THERE.
THIS IS A NEW MOVE TOWARDS
DIPLOMACY.
IT'S ONE WHETHER THEY RESPECT.
THEY'VE ALWAYS USED IT IN THE
PAST MOST OF THE TIME AS A
STALLING MECHANISM, TIME TO
REGROUP.
WINTER IS CERTAINLY COMING HERE.
RUSSIA IS IN SEVERE TROUBLE ON
THE BATTLEFIELD.
THEY'VE SAID THEY'RE GOING TO
EVACUATE CIVILIANS IN THE
SOUTHERN CITY OF KHERSON.
SUPPLY CHAINS ARE DIFFICULT.
A LOT CHANGING.
BACK TO YOU.
>> NICK PEYTON WALSH FOR US IN
CENTRAL UKRAINE.